Haley and Justin Bieber not letting
pressures of Fame privacy and gossip
affect their relationship I don't want
to read stuff because I don't want to
read negative stuff and then be upset
you know a source tells ET the pair is
able to let it all go with just a bit of
one-on-one time together we have a good
time together
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
he's a good heart and uh I love him they
love taking vacations and seeing new
places gives them the freedom to be
their most authentic selves it's an
amazing feeling
yeah the couple's been spending lots of
time abroad sharing these moments of
their European vacay on social media and
et's learned they're excited to relax
and create new memories with family and
friends this summer that's about it and
this quality time well it's only making
their relationship stronger we worked
very hard to like be in the space that
we're in now and like
trusting each other
ET Source tells us the lovebirds are
committed to each other through
everything regardless of the
circumstance the trust Faith love and
respect they have for one another holds
their relationship together if your core
Foundation isn't supporting you then
you're just gonna you're just not gonna
be balanced I think that that's it just
shows how much I care he's my best
friend I love coming home to him we're
busy people and we want to be in a
marriage so we're making it work this
comes as Haley's making it known she's
had enough of the online hate the 26
year old seemingly responding to people
leaving nasty messages on Selena Gomez's
posts amid their rumored Feud writing on
Instagram if you're leaving mean or rude
comments on my behalf on anyone's post I
don't want that doing that is not
supporting me if you are participating
in that you are part of the culture that
I want no part of on social media it's
as much as it's a blessing and it's fun
it it can really tear people down down
and I always hope that the people I'm
involved with or support me can just
kind of spread love within that would
neither of us owe anybody anything
except like respect I respect her a lot
and
I think that like there's just no
expectation there's no drama personally
foreign